[Music]
foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored he's
the most dangerous and notorious
conspiracy theorist on the planet Alex
Jones owes 1.5 billion dollars for The
Grieving families of the Sandy Hook
massacre for the accused of being actors
and a government hoax he hasn't so far
paid a stent and he's still spreading
untruth to millions of people
unchallenged so tonight I'm going to
challenge him this is what happened last
time that we met
how many gun murders were there in brit
how many great white sharks how many
kill people every year but they're
scared to swim and I'm here to tell you
1776 will commence again if you try to
take our firearm
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening London welcome
to pairs Morgan uncensed we've been
feasting on Prince Harry's grotesque
reality show attacks on his family well
tonight you might be deeply relieved to
hear we're gonna have a night off
today the real Royal show went on the
Prince of Wales was asked about that
book
have you had a chance to read your
brother's puppet
and he gave a dignified silence as all
the royal family have done and that's
surely the right way to respond and on
their web with dignity Duty and it
turned out the full support of the
British people listen to this
well I created a show called uncensored
because I believe passionately in free
speech in a moment I'll be talking to
Alex Jones live and unsensitive for
exactly that reason we've reached a
dangerous moment in our culture honestly
held opinions and debates are stifled by
fear people have vilified abused
harassed sometimes even fired from their
jobs because their opinions deviate from
the sanitized worldview of a militant
minority I thought that being uncensored
would mean taking on the kinds of
debates and ideas other interviewers are
afraid of and to a large degree we have
what I didn't realize is that it would
actually come down to this that the word
field f-i-e-l-d
is now offensive it's racist
reporters on assignment are described as
working in the field aren't scientists
and researchers have a field of study
they conduct field work when they
interview Ordinary People or study
biology in the wild we have country
feels Level Playing Fields football
fields walking Fields force fields a
Field of Dreams
not anymore
University of Southern California's
banned the word field because as I said
it's racist apparently Elite letter
explains that field may have
connotations for descendants of slavery
and immigrant workers that are not
benign it goes on our goal is not just
to change language but to honor and
acknowledge inclusion and reject white
supremacy anti-immigrant and
anti-blackness ideologies
what does any of that even mean does
that mean that no white person has ever
worked in a field
it might come as news to the millions of
white Farmers around the world
nobody as far as I'm aware in the entire
swoop of human history has ever used the
word field offensively it's one of the
least offensive words imaginable isn't
it field just conjures up nice imagery
I don't think it's ever crossed any sane
person's mind that the word field could
have any possible connection with white
supremacy for those who think this is
just one irrelevant set of moronic
virtue signalers are sadly it's not
our language is under constant attack
local governments in England tried to
ban the words like ladies and gentlemen
and Mum and Dad
Stanford one of the top universities in
America banned the word American because
it might upset South Americans the
British NHS uses words like chest
feeding and birthing parent because 0.3
percent of the population is transgender
they may take offense to words like
mother
the Cambridge Dictionary says a woman is
an adult who lives and identifies as a
female that they may have been said to
have a different sex at Birth what does
that gobbledygo even mean
this matters because it's Insidious
if you have to hesitate before using
perfectly normal words like field
because somebody's warned you they might
be offensive or racist
then that world view has already been
imposed upon you they've won you've
committed the thought crime they're
accusing us all of doing and anybody who
gives a damn about free speech
and Common Sense
should fight this nonsense
now that doesn't mean that anything goes
Free Speech has its limits even in
America with its Fable First Amendment
there are limits you can't famously run
into a theater in America and shout fire
and create a stampede where people might
die so there are limits to free speech
all around the world
but my guest tonight
well he tests free speech to I would
argue it's breaking point his name is
Alex Jones he's a hugely influential to
many people a very dangerous conspiracy
theorist he's made himself hugely Rich
peddling a lot of lies this is what
happened when we met last debating gun
laws a decade ago on CNN
how many gun murders were there in
Britain how many great white sharks how
many kill people every year but they're
scared to swim and I'm here to tell you
1776 will commence again if you try to
take our Firearms but you've got hordes
of people burning down cities and
beating old women's Brains out every day
let's try again how many gun murders
were there oh we're gonna ban your
Festival in Britain last year uh how
many uh chimpanzees can dance on the
head of a pin
well I've not spoken to Alex Jones in an
interview format uh since that day uh he
is now uh I would say comfortably the
world's most notorious conspiracy
theorist as I say I defend everybody's
right to an honestly held opinion I
defend everyone's right to use words of
their choice but it doesn't mean they're
not accountable for those words
uh and I don't think Alex Jones
necessarily trades in honestly held
opinions but we'll come to that when I
talk to him very few tragedies have ever
moved me the way that Sandy Hook did I
was on air as CNN at the time that that
story broke 20 children age 15 6 and 7
were murdered by a lunatic with a
semi-automatic rifle Alex Jones told his
many followers within a few hours it was
all a hoax a government hoax a deep
State plot to justify seizing guns he
said that the grieving families were
actors
the general public doesn't know the
school was actually closed the year
before they don't know they've shielded
all demolished the building they don't
know that uh they have the kids going in
circles in and out of the building as a
photo op blue screen green screens but
it took me about a year with Sandy Hook
to come to grips with the fact that the
whole thing was fake I mean even I
couldn't believe it I knew they jumped
on it used the crisis hyped it up but
then I did deep research and my gosh it
just pretty much didn't happen
but it did happen those children did get
murdered
they were riddled with Bullets by an
AR-15 semi-automatic rifle I can't even
imagine as a father of four kids what
that site must have looked like those
parents had to see their children
riddled with bullets
and then they had to put up with years
of harassment and threats
and disgraceful incidents
because Alex Jones fueled a conspiracy
theory almost immediately that the whole
thing was fake and that these parents
who were grieving for their dead
children
that they were actors
I have made my views clear about that
but I also think that it's right that I
should interview him tonight uh he
wanted to come on and talk to me and to
explain what's gone down here and where
he's found himself which is facing a 1.5
billion dollar payout to the families in
various lawsuits that they took and I do
believe that people should be allowed to
express themselves as long as they're
held to account and they're challenged
on that and that's what we're going to
do tonight with Alex Jones so my guest
tonight is Alex Jones he's over in Texas
and America Alex uh good evening to you
Pierce it's good to be here with you
after 10 years and the biggest news
event on CNN in 2013 so the circle is
now complete but you just spent eight
minutes
saying a lot of things that were true a
lot of things that weren't true so I'd
like to address that right now if I can
when I came on your show months and
months after Sandy Hook
in the CNN Studios in New York I never
said it didn't happen I never sent
people their houses when the internet
went totally viral in the next year
questioning it with anomalies I did
Cover 23 minutes is what they introduced
in court over the next few years a few
times we're talking five six shows
what the internet was questioning on my
call-in radio show with a document cam
on air but I did not build my career
Sandy Hook I barely not even one tenth
of one percent
covered it and so to say that I sent
people to harass families or I didn't
say that eat on the graves I don't say
that I didn't say you sent me one to do
anything
let me let me just say I want to have a
reasonable conversation I don't get into
the screaming match that descended into
last time I think that's futile for
everyone watching you are now a very
Infamous person around the world you
know that a lot of people know about you
what they've read most of it negative
this is your chance to explain what's
happened and to if you want to uh
Express remorse for the things that
you've got wrong and done wrong you find
yourself in a very bad place right now
you're facing paying out potentially 1.5
billion dollars to these families you
said that you don't have that money you
can't pay that money so far you haven't
paid any of the money uh how do you feel
first of all about the fact that you
faced this gigantic
uh well victory for the families and
defeat for you
okay so you did eight minutes and 45
seconds attacking me I got 30 seconds I
will answer your question a moment but I
want to get something completely
straight I came on your show months and
months and months and months after it
happened I blamed the serotonin reuptake
Inhibitors the antidepressants I blame
the mother getting him the gun on your
show so the claim that I first
questioned Sandy Hook or I first did it
was a bunch of professors and a bunch of
media people became a huge story I
looked at it and said yeah we've seen
wmds in Iraq we've seen operation
Northwoods we see Justin smallett later
we see now admitted the Twitter files
that they had thousands of fake doctors
online saying the shot was safe and
effective and protected you something
you've come out and said was wrong and
was a lie so I always questioned every
major event but I did not make my bones
on Sandy Hook I barely covered it on
your show months and months and months
after it happened
long after listen I don't you may well
categorize this as a very small small
part of your career unfortunately for
you it's now become this gigantic part
of your career because of the nature of
this payouts I'm like that's totally
true specifically to ask you what did
you feel about the size of the payout
you've been ordered to pay and the fact
that you suffered one of the biggest
losses of any lawsuit of that nature in
modern history
well I mean it's not one of the biggest
it's the biggest and uh so so if you
actually want the inside baseball to
know what actually went on I'm really
happy to tell you I'm more interested
Alex and how you you built this Empire
and I'm going to come to how you built
it in a moment you built this Empire as
a very uh provocative many would argue
they found you very entertaining as well
high energy uh you know Mischief making
shock jock for want of a better phrase
who went on the airwaves and said a lot
of very controversial things and built
up a very big following and made a vast
amount of money doing it
um I mean you wouldn't dispute any of
that right that's not attacking you
that's just a statement of fact so
listen but I'm happy to come on but
you've had 90 of the talk time
I just want you to answer it
I understand again I don't want to have
a confrontational interview I simply
want to ask you
as I say you've built this big Empire
and now the entire Empire has been
imperiled by losing this lawsuit and you
wouldn't dispute that no
no I had more than 15 offers right now
on huge networks if if my system goes
under let me just explain something to
you and let's talk facts okay here's a
timeline of 10 and a half years since or
10 years two months in Sandy Hook
it happens the first year I don't think
it's staged it becomes a huge internet
thing that it's staged I have a few
debates I'm a few guests on I covered I
said yeah it could be staged so much
stuff is staged then I go two plus years
2015 into 16 never discussing it this
all came out in the lawsuit
and then they run against Trump Hillary
runs 30 million dollars of TV ads
showing edited clips of me saying
synthetic event never happened and then
Trump still wins and we now learned
after the lawsuits they hired a
high-powered New York Think Tank
PR firm to then make it a huge story
tens of thousands of Articles thousands
of newscasts about me in 2016-17 about
San Diego I go whoa those anomalies I
heard from those professors and people
were wrong I think it happened nobody
sued me no one Joe Rogan apologize do a
whole apology to her because that wasn't
sophisticated back then I'm like yeah I
think it happened I barely covered it
then they sue me once I apologize they
have a judge in Texas in Austin this is
liberal in San Francisco and a
Connecticut
sue me then I give them all my text all
my documents which they show in court
but say I gave them no documents they
default me first time in modern U.S
history I'm found guilty by judges and
juries then have hearings on how guilty
I am that they have a false Financial
expert get up and say I'm worth 400
million dollars at the time they did
that six months ago in that hearing in
Texas and that kangaroo operation I had
like three million dollars in the bank
what do you say okay all right let me
let me see hold on you can't just keep
talking Alex let me just explain to you
what I think oh God forbid I get a third
of the time you get well you know what
it's my show it's the way it works on
your show again 90 of the time on your
show if I was a guest you don't want to
uh I'm just telling you I just want to
have a no one have a real discussion
let's have a normal debate I want to
play you a clip this is a clip of one of
the uh parents from Sandy Hook because
you've talked about this at length now
Nicole Hockley and I want to talk after
this clip I want you to just listen to
what she had to say to me recently on
the show
he did his first broadcast saying that
he thought this was a false flag
when I was still in the firehouse and I
didn't even know if my child was alive
or dead yet he started off within two
and a half hours of the shooting and has
kept putting out video after video for
year after year after year and calling
us all crisis actors calling our
children you know either that they were
never they were never killed or they
were never alive in the first place
that were traders that were were
treasonous and that were government
chills it's been very difficult it's
been easy to turn off some of it but
some of these people have been
incredibly dangerous and when he says
when he when he Stokes this anger in his
base this fear and then incites them to
action by saying you know we need to
investigate this you need to look into
this more they come at us so part of
it's just social media comments which
can be damaging it's defaming it's
hurting your reputation people I don't
know if I'm walking around who thinks
I'm real and who thinks I'm an actress
it's it's damaging to my son's memory in
terms of his life his short six-year-old
life it's damaging to my surviving son
because I don't know what he's going to
deal with going forward but it's also
scared The Living Daylights out of me I
sleep with weapons by my bedside I've
received death threats I've received
harassing calls and mail I've had people
send me pictures of dead children
because they say as a crisis actor you
have no idea what a dead child looks
like so let me send you this picture so
you can see it this is stuff that has
really not only just been distressing
it's disturbing and in terms of security
you know I'm just a mom I'm just trying
to look after my surviving Son run my
organization and make some good in the
world I didn't choose to be part of this
Alex Jones chose to tell lies
knowing that they were lies and
continuing to Harbor that lie and make
it happen for his own prophet
what's your reaction to that woman who
lost her son Dylan at Sandy Hook
total garbage never said her name only
person's name I shed was Robbie Parker
30 something million views on YouTube he
was laughing everything suddenly started
so your response your response to that
woman's incredibly powerful sugar give
me five seconds
this is well I guess I can't do this
interview people have to go to
infowars.com later and I'll respond to
you you're not letting me talk I never
said her name under Connecticut and
Texas law you can't sue somebody for
defamation if you never said their name
I didn't do any of those things I was on
your show months and months after it
happened and said it happened and said
it was Prozac I looked at both of the
views and they clipped that out to
attach themselves to me on air I never
talked about that woman I didn't even
know who she was I said it was a husband
you said it was a hoax you said it was
funny Bill he said the entire thing is a
giant hoax
Bin Laden raid people just know there's
a lot of fraud going on you've got
here's what I'm gonna say to you parents
wait a second here let me talk about
five seconds let me finish you sent me a
list of topics let me finish the topic I
gotta come to this said I'd come on and
one of them is Sandy Hook I'm on for an
hour let's talk about the Davos group
yes let's talk about the world let's
talk about the internet let's talk about
the vaccines then are we going to talk
about other topics because they're
attacked they live off me I didn't make
money off
73 million dollars they live off Sandy
Hook I don't okay here's what I would
say to you maybe one of the reasons that
they have a problem with you and what
you did is that you were saying on there
things like you've got parents laughing
hahaha then they walk over to the camera
and go boo hoo hoo and not just one but
a bunch of parents doing this and then
photos of kids that are still alive they
say dead I mean they think we're so dumb
these were parents people I told you
an unbelievable trauma
yeah listen and Madeleine Albright
Secretary of State under Clinton was
asked by Leslie Stahl in 60 minutes that
Clinton tripled sanctions on Iraq to
kill two million people 500 000 children
she said it was a good thing to do she'd
do it again I didn't kill 500 000
children I question all these events
because many of them are provocateur I
understand that but I also understand
that immediate all the kids dying from
The Poisoned shots let me just
admitting it causes
the problem is I deserve to die for
questioning a mass shooting then what
happens to the big companies that sold
these poison shots that weren't approved
and weren't safe here's my question but
then while you're I get I'm the worst
guy in the world so Pierce hold on hold
on I'm the worst guy in the world right
I didn't say that
I listen I told them in a deposition
that back when this went on and I
started questioning it like nine years
ago about a year after
when I said false flag I believe they
may have protected him they may have
known it was coming like Uvaldi 75
minutes the police stood down I believe
that was a real shooter real kids died
uh in Florida at Parkland there was a
stand down why the police chief said
well he thought he'd already killed all
the kids so he didn't want more death
that was in the news that was the Dallas
Morning News yesterday I'm questioning
Parkland saying did they let it happen
that's a false flag to say a false flag
doesn't mean the parents are fake I
apologized
on Joe Rogan before I was sued I
apologized on dozens of shows when they
brought this up in 2016. here's my
question here's my question then they
went on the news and said I was
currently sending people their houses
where is the video of me saying go to
their houses where is the video be
pissing on their graves it's not true
they're raising money on my nails let me
let me respond I want to just try and
get inside your head for a moment and
see whether you have ever fully
comprehended
scale of what happened to these families
because as things stand I believe 20 of
Americans one in five believe that mass
shootings like Sandy Hook are staged a
lot of that is down to somebody like you
with your huge following which you built
up consistently suggesting their stage
including Sandy Hook this is what
happened to some of the families okay
Erica Lafferty whose mother was killed
has had to move five times since the
shooting and avoids going to the grocery
store because people tell us
any evidence
the judges found me guilty that's
illegal I know let me just finish she
said it got scary and more graphic
things would be mailed to her house to
the threats of rape
Jennifer Hensel and Jeremy Rickman
parents of six-year-old aviel who was
killed set up a foundation for their
daughter soon after email addresses
attached to the foundation by black
lives matter let me finish with flooded
with messages saying Advil didn't exist
the Hensel and others were actors and
questioned why money was being raised
from a fake shooting in 2019 Jeremy
Rickman advil's father killed himself
friends called Hensel his wife Jennifer
to tell her people were at the cemetery
where Avia was buried looking for
evidence that her husband had actually
died
David wheeler the father of six-year-old
Ben Wheeler who died at Sandy Hook
detailed two instances in which people
actually showed up at his home demanding
to see Ben insisting he was alive he
said people also pointed to a student
film he made in college as proof he was
a crisis actor Robbie and Alyssa Parker
and you did mention Robbie Parker who I
interviewed many times and felt a deep
Affinity with and he said he was
laughing after his his uh
but she said that his wife said that the
vicious comments in the memorial
Facebook page honoring his daughter was
so terrifying she couldn't remember much
of her daughter's funeral
Mark banston the lawyer representation
you said one of your topics was Sandy
Hook here's the deal they know they
showed no proof of that in court the
judge didn't let me defend myself okay
you just want to sit here and talk about
Santa
on other topics I'm simply my question
is simply this when you hear about the
impact on these poor families whose
children aged six were blown to pieces
in a school when you hear about the
impact do you have any real regret or
remorse about fueling animals
let me talk at all
Adam Lanza killed those children not me
a Democratic party PR firm looked at
Trump looked at me in 2007. that wasn't
my question brought up Sandy Hook that
wasn't my question explain to you again
I'm gonna say again the media took what
I said out of context they didn't years
later magnified it let me finish to make
a political hit point on me and on Trump
and they blew it all up and then said I
was doing it they have no proof ever
Sydney by their houses I didn't I a few
times questioned it on air I became
Super Famous
to me they've raised hundreds of
millions in in donations 73 million from
Remington now they're coming after the
first amendment it's insane and I told
you I'd come on and briefly talk about
Sandy Hook you sent a whole list of
topics now I want you to be true to your
word and not a deceptive person peers we
have spent 24 minutes on Sandy Hook I
want to move on to the Davos group so
the question first before we move on do
you feel like when you hit these when
you hear these accounts of what happened
to these families do you feel a sense of
personal regret and remorse that you're
actually that your actions
a lot of people to think these people
were actors and their kids didn't really
die do you feel genuine
let me talk for any all five thousand
Iraqi children starve to death
oh you know I feel way less no I
legitimately question Sandy Hook and I
stand by what I did said it was a
village and a hoax you let me finish
attach themselves to me to raise money
and to claim I'm doing things with them
I didn't do to raise money and to try to
take over my life and no I don't I
apologize before they sued me if I ever
hurt anybody's feelings and I'm supposed
to apologize forever and ever in some
communism
I just asked you whether you feel
regretable I asked you whether you feel
regrets and remorse for fueling this
belief that Sandy Hook was staged and
fake that's the only question I asked
you
when you give an apology which I've
given over 150 times you're done with
the apology type in Alex Jones
apologizes for Sandy Hook you'll have it
before they sued me so I'll point you to
that you're so good at all your Clips
but no I'm not going to come back on
your show in 10 years and you'll say do
you now apologize if I sat here and slit
my throat on air it would be enough for
you I legitimately question Mass events
because of things like operation
Northwoods that call for staging mass
shootings that didn't occur in the
United States look it up ABC news
Operation Northwoods I came on here
Pierce to have a real discussion with
you and ask for money
imagine the biggest settlement ever
fentanyl uh settlements for Oxycontin
settlements that have killed millions of
people and this settlement is way bigger
and they say Jones refuses to pay I
don't have five million dollars much
less a billion and a half dollars so
when they say I refuse to pay if I have
three gallons of blood in my body and
they say we want a thousand gallons I
don't have a thousand gallons of blood
Alex we'll come back and we will talk
about other things off the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back Alex Jones is still
with me as we'll move on to other things
I looked at the Infowars website tonight
you were leading uh several hours ago
actually on the story which I addressed
at the top of the show which is about
this ludicrous idea that the word field
is racist I'm sure there are a number of
things like that on which we would have
complete agreement but I also found a
piece on your website near the top today
which said the following falsehoods have
far-reaching costs in livelihoods and
lives lack of integrity and conflicts of
interest have led to an unprecedented
institutional false information pandemic
there was nothing that dispels false
narratives better than personal inquiry
and critical thinking so the next time
conflicted institutions cry woeful wolf
or vicious variant or whatever it is we
need to think twice a very strong worded
piece there about the danger of
falsehoods do you agree with that
well let me answer your question and
we'll finish up the Sandy Hook thing I
wish that I wasn't misled by some of
those professors and people that thought
that it was staged it was a very small
part of what I did I tried to apologize
I tried to settle I tried to make
restitution and then they misrepresented
when I was in the Texas trial you can
look at this
uh they had uh one of the mothers on who
lost her son and I went on my show that
morning and taped it before I went to
court I said I think she's real I think
her son died I'd seen her testimony the
day before and I'm very sorry that Adam
Lanza did this and then she went on the
stand and said Jones attacked me and
said I'm an actress it's all fake today
and I walked over to her during the
break and I said watch my show from
today your lawyers lied to you and the
next day she came up and cried and shook
my hand
and Scarlett Lewis and said oh my God
it's true I I saw you did say that so
there's a lot of manipulation here look
I didn't do this consciously I think
their children died but I think you're
being manipulated by groups I wish I
never would have said it we do have to
have uh got you know guidelines I have
messed up a lot in my life peers and
listen that's what I said a love-hate
relationship with you and I sent you an
audio message yesterday I watched the
intro to your show and I was like man I
wish I was as good as this guy because I
covered the same stuff today but the way
you brought up them saying the word
America is bad and the way you pointed
out that it's not by itself that it's a
cult that wants a crow language I was
like that guy's a master of really
understanding this attack on our freedom
and I wish he knew that I was a real guy
honestly the difference between us I
would say is this I have always strived
not always successfully but I've always
strived in my career to put a premium on
accuracy and facts because I think
without that you have nothing I would
argue and this is your chance to to
dispel this notion that over the years
you have deliberately and systematically
used conspiracy theories which I suspect
you know are not true to fuel interest
in a large number of people who then go
and buy your products which you sell
which are a massive part of your
business and have made you hundreds of
millions of dollars and I'm going to
give you some examples collectively so
let me just read them hold on everybody
I'll give you a chance to respond when I
read them but you know this is some of
the stuff you said on air right in 2017
you had to apologize after promoting the
infamous pizzagate fake story that a
Washington pizza restaurant was the
Locale of a child's sex abuse ring run
by Hillary Clinton and her campaign
chairman after 9 11 you called it an
inside job perpetrated by the US
government you said that chemicals in
the water which are put there by the
government are turning frogs gay in a
gay bomb you said Michelle Obama is a
man in a 12-minute video you analyze
footage of photographs proving that Mrs
Obama has a penis you said that Robert
Muller the former FBI director who
investigated Trump's Russia ties which
turned out to be like can we stop can we
hold on each one of these things
he's obviously not a pedophile and so on
so here's my point Alex hey are you
there you keep flashing up your info you
don't need to promote info walls we all
know about it listening on the front
page
and I can't respond let me ask you the
question I'm about to ask you I read a
piece on Infowars all about the danger
of falsehoods right the cost to
livelihoods and lives the problem with
lack of integrity and the false
information pandemic your website is
promoting that thinking that it's wrong
to have false information but other and
yet the guy behind the website making
all the money is the guy saying all this
stuff which is obviously
you know it's nonsense don't you you're
scared to let me talk your chance to
respond no I don't know it's nonsense
and if you took your time through all
those points you just raised I can back
every one of them there are more than a
thousand University studies from England
to Australia to South Africa to Mexico
to Austin Texas that atrazine is
literally making male frogs gay they
don't want to have sex with female frogs
and their populations are plummeting and
even becoming extinct boom then 9 11. I
don't think radical Islam doesn't exist
there were criminal elements of my in
our government that it came out even in
the hearings that stood down and did
nothing so you rattle off 9 11 was not
an inside job Michelle Obama is not a
man Robert Muller is not a demonstrator
Obama let me talk about Michelle Obama
let me talk about Big Mike these are all
ridiculous lives and here's the point
Alex you're not as stupid just repeat it
again
you know these things I'm gonna talk
over you
let me talk
it was that is a transcript you have
I was playing a clip
of Joan Rivers two months before she
died
with fire exploding out of her mouth in
a surgery she said Michelle Obama is a
[ __ ] everybody knows that we already
have a gay president and I was quoting
what she said and and I was questioning
what people were saying That's Joan
Rivers now let's move on what was the
other one what was the other one you
were saying robot Mueller is a demonic
pedophile
Robert Mueller is definitely okay let's
talk about pizzagate I didn't regenerate
Pizza gate it was in the Wikileaks
documents a whole bunch of Aleister
Crowley Satan you apologize because you
promoted that conspiracy theory too
here's my point Alex I don't think you
really believe any of these things I
think you realized early on in your life
that there was a lot of money to be made
from fueling conspiracy theories and you
have made it you're right
I said Jeffrey Epstein 13 years ago ran
an island in the Caribbean with
kidnapped children I said the Nexium
cult was branding people five years
before broke no I had the sources and I
had the guts I lost viewers saying Sandy
Hook might have been staged I lost some
of my reporters that is not true what
you're saying I don't sit there and
think of a story I'm gonna say I've got
too many stories here
and then say Oh I'm going to lie about
this thing I said Jesse smallett despite
the fact I was already sued by Sandy
Hook I said the day after it before
anybody else I said I think it staged I
think at 2 30 in the morning 22 below I
agree I thought he said guys walking
around so here's my point now again
my question for you believe it you are a
smart enough person
from interviews I've seen of you with
Joe Rogan for three hours you're more
than smart enough to do a show where you
genuinely examine stories like justice
Moller and you ask the right questions
as a journalist would do but I don't
think you are a journalist I know that
you're not saying I'm a trained
journalist but you don't come at it like
a journalist you come at it as a
commercial operator who's made a fortune
from fueling conspiracy theories which
are ludicrous and to a point be
responsibility
so it appears you had me here let me
respond to each lie let me finish your
goal is to spill let me finish I'm I'm
going to tell you again I'm gonna tell
you again I'm not against capitalism and
the people earn money normally and
actually that's great if I sell 70
million dollars of food and supplements
and books and films and we make 20
million dollars off that and I pay my
career and my bandwidth and pay myself a
couple million dollars a year that is
accurate but the idea that I have
billions of dollars and the idea that I
that I did I think you've made billions
of dollars I think you've made several
hundred million dollars and some of the
products included uh very false claims
about diet supplements and toothpaste
which could be used to fight coronavirus
and you were sent to cease and disease
all I said is is that silver on contact
kills all viruses just like sunlight and
I said vitamin D3 is an antiviral and
vitamin C is and it's a fact and I also
said beers that the studies they'd
already done with mRNA vaccines showed
they didn't protect you and they erased
your immune system and you've had to
apologize
no no just to clarify they do protect
you from coronavirus the difference was
a year into the pandemic it was it
emerged that the initial feeling that if
you had the vaccine you couldn't
transmit it turned out to be wrong but
they didn't realize
today
Nuremberg too you're going to stand in
Nuremberg to all did you get money from
Big Pharma no I didn't get any of these
other media people I'm gonna say yeah
listen the vaccines what did you get
money did you get money yeah millions of
Lies however let's take a short break
one last question
infowars.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to my final segment with
Alex Jones Alex on uh Daniel vi at the
infamous January the sixth you stood
there writing the crowns up by saying we
declare 1776 against the New World Order
we need to understand under attack we
need to understand Mrs 21st century
Warfare and get on the wall footing and
within several hours that's exactly what
thousands of people did they went down
from hearing you say that and Donald
Trump saying what he said and they
launched an unprecedented attack on the
capital the very center of Democracy in
America uh do you regret now what you
said at that speech
uh no I don't I'd had rallies with over
a million people a half million people
before that it's an information War
infowars.com we're in an information War
we were there to have a 10-day
investigation of the Constitution the
Democrats have done it before just a few
years before to look at what was
happening we were there peaceful and
then peers I tried to stop people and
did keep thousands from going into the
Capitol and I've been cleared in the
January 6th look at the Reuters just to
be clear do you denounce those who use
violence that day yes I denounced
rayup's telling uh the Congressional
committee that he orchestrated the
attack and I tried to stop the
provocateurs uh in that operation from
breaking in we had a million people
there they tricked a thousand or so to
go in a few hundred provocateurs broke
through the police similar to what we're
seeing uh in Brazil and so I'm on record
there that day telling people don't go
in the building and trying to stop it
when I say 1776 I'm saying try to take
our guns 1776. try to take our Free
Speech 1776 it means political Rebellion
it means an Awakening it means saying no
has one of the lessons that you've
learned from this lawsuit with the Sandy
Hook families has one of the lessons
been that actually truth matters have
you learned that do you believe now that
you need to focus on saying things which
are true because consequences can be
very serious
you keep trying to act like it was a big
part of what I've covered or that I made
mistakes on purpose the whole currency I
operate in is the truth and we're
accurate 95 percent of the time I make
big mistakes and when I make mistakes we
absolutely admit to it I think you've
done that yourself sometime so I'll you
know here's the deal maybe in 10 years
you're still alive I'm alive I'm back on
you'll say will you apologize now I
apologize if I cause any pain I've
already done it it only makes them more
rabid and attack more and misrepresent I
went on my show during the trial and
said I love you I think you're real I'm
so sorry for your child they went on the
stand and said I attacked them that day
that's all on record and and so the
problem is the reason the problem is
political movements
of millions of dollars Alex off they're
dead kids the problem is you did make
millions of dollars from their dead kids
it's one of the reasons
I make millions of dollars off of my
number one book it's the reason it's the
reason age right the reason Elon Musk
has refused to let you back on Twitter
is he won't let people on who trade off
dead children that's exactly what you
did
so Marilyn Albright kills 500 000
sessions
of mass shooting I I get it I'm the
worst guy in the world I didn't say that
dying corporate meaning I didn't say
that Alex Jones is bad but here's the
thing infowars.com lives people can come
to my show every day 11 A.M Central and
they can hear what I'm actually saying
peers versus what you're trying to put
in my mouth I see all I'm putting into
your mouth are things that have come out
of your mouth
no you don't have footage of me saying
go harass them with their houses
you don't have any of that YouTube
all I know is for all your postures when
those poor families don't let peers
we're going through the most exclusive
you took a massive amount of fuel
about other events
of Sandy for human trafficking what
about defense
is utterly contemptible and we both
you're never gonna get our first
amendment and I'm glad you had to move
back to England to live under your
Islamic takeover and when they're
arresting people
transgenderism you once again losing the
plot so now I have to say goodbye
well then don't be a
Liars nothing's really changed other
than in the last 10 years or so he
carried on exploiting particularly the
families of Sandy Hook for massive
personal financial gain he
systematically tell us this Thursday
theories of China he knows I'm not true
and he does it because it makes him tons
of money and he's got away with it until
now but now they called his bluff they
sued him and the family's won 1.5
billion dollars and he may not have that
but we'll have to give a lot of money to
them
and that's what Alex Jones is about he's
a guy who's conspiracy theories to make
money and doesn't care about the
consequences and finally he caught up
with him
after the break we'll discuss what we've
just been hearing with my pack they've
been listening shaking their heads open
mouths and occasion to get their
reaction off the page
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
exhausted after all that welcome back
joining me now to look back at the Alex
Jones interview I guess we called it
that today's pack talk to the
international artist Isabel Oh shot
Daily Mirror Associated to Kevin McGuire
I talked to the contributor Paul
oronator we've received very patiently
because we weren't entirely sure if he
was going to walk it was like he might
do at various stages in which case he
would have had a lot longer but what are
your thoughts I mean what do you make of
this guys he's become the most infamous
conspiracy there is in the world he's
now going to pay all this money to the
families of Sandy Hook uh and he is what
he is but he has a huge following so
even though it's been de-platformed by
all the social media companies and even
though Elon Musk won't even have him
back he still has a huge following and
is out there broadcasting and it's just
so dangerous isn't it that that we are
witnessing this that even after he has
had this court case even after there has
been a Judicial decision it still seems
to be that hey he doesn't accept it and
B his millions of followers don't accept
it and that concerns me I mean Kevin one
in five Americans thinks that these mass
shootings lights on a good stage a lot
of that is down to people like Alex
Jones probably getting there I mean
maybe some people saying well don't give
him a platform I don't think we're
giving him a platform I'm interviewing
him to challenge him about this stuff
he's done
um and I think this that has a place I
think journalists should challenge it
yeah it's about interrogating them
holding him to uh accountability that's
what it is I think you were wrong
yesterday I think she may begum
shouldn't be a BBC podcast
is really about hers I don't think she
should come back that's fine I don't
like BBC taxpayer money being used to
promote a 10-part series of why I'm not
a monster
she may not be a Monster yeah
it's all about understanding yeah and I
watched Alex Jones there he's a nasty
piece of work but I think he's also a
deflating win bag because he's very
defensive now and it reminded me of the
end of The Wizard of Oz when the
curtainers pulled back and the great
wizard turns out be a little a little
man that's what jamesabel what did you
think of it I mean he didn't of new
favors I mean there were times when you
played that clip of the of the mother
and she was an incredibly powerful
witness as to the pain that he had
caused and you said you know what's your
response to that and he said I was
genuinely shocked by that there was no
Humanity there no compassion whatsoever
I've been a bit conflicted about this
because I accept that you know as you
say one in five Americans are buying
into this nonsense also like you I'm
very Pro free speech and the word
dangerous is used far too liberally in
his case I think it's actually Justified
I think the time you see the
consequences of what these families had
to go through even though he didn't
personally turn up and do the harassment
or cause them the problems he did
subliminally because he's uh he's on the
Airways fueling this sense the whole
thing was finished so the Dilemma for us
as broadcasters is the extent to which
we choose to amplify this yeah and I
think that's a really difficult Essence
is the guy right he is clever uh is not
a Charlotte but he is clever he's the
he's the guy who gets the mob with the
pitchforks and the Torches to go and
burn down the house
to actually believe these conspiracy
theories he never for a moment thought
Sandy Hook was finished that's my
problem with it he every time he went on
the airwaves and said it was a fatal
hoax apparently his money doubled that
day that came out of the Court yeah
especially there was a direct link
between the lie and the money why
actually you needed to have this
interview that's why you actually needed
to do this because he is out there and
others out there are exist and the
millions are out there at this and can I
say that you know where Isabelle and I
disagree well together because that's
what we do we disagree well is on the
extent of that freedom of expression
because it's going to get worse we have
deep fake we have to like I think the
light honestly I think the line is you
should not be allowed to spew deliberate
lies that put people's lives into
Jeopardy I agree well you cause them
direct harassment or threats of violence
well actually it has possibly stopped in
because of his payout we've got to leave
it there listen thank you Pat because
you were very patient and you were there
and just in case he never came back
working on my listening skills thanks
very much whatever you're doing tonight
keep it unsensitive good night
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]